FINALLY A USE OF MY WRIST I CAN
GET BEHIND!
WELL, A SECOND USE OF MY WRIST I
CAN GET BEHIND.
(LAUGHTER)
I'M TOTALLY GETTING ONE.
WHAT CAN I SAY?
I'M A BLERD.
THAT MEANS BLACK NERD, FOR THOSE
OF YOU PLAYING AT HOME.
AND REMEMBER, "OTHER IN OTHER
-- AND REMEMBER OTHER NERDS,
ONLY WE CAN CALL EACH OTHER
THAT.
BUT WHENEVER I'M WAITING THE
ARRIVAL OF A FRESH NEW APPLE
PRODUCT,
I GET A TINGLY FEELING.
BUT NOT THE GOOD KIND IN MY
BATHING SUIT AREA.
IT'S LIKE THERE'S SOMETHING I'M
SUPPOSED TO REMEMBER ABOUT APPLE
THAT'S NOT SO PLEASANT.
>> THIS IS WHERE YOUR iPhone 6
COMES FROM.
>> AT FOXCON, "WOMEN WORK LIKE
MEN AND MEN WORK LIKE ANIMALS."
>> A TOTAL OF 18 EMPLOYEES TOOK
THEIR OWN LIVES OR TRIED TO IN
RECENT YEARS.
SUICIDE NETS WENT UP IN THE
SPRING OF 2010.
>> Larry: THIS IS WHY APPLE
FRUSTRATES ME SO MUCH. THEY
FORCE YOU TO GO THROUGH AN
INTERNAL ETHICAL ISSUE BEFORE
EVERY PURCHASE.
WHAT DO I CARE ABOUT, THE PROPER
TREATMENT OF HUMAN BEINGS OR
CRUSHING CANDY?
I MEAN, I LIKE PEOPLE, BUT THESE
PEOPLE ARE SO FAR AWAY
THEY'RE IN CHINA!
WHEREAS ALL OF THIS CANDY IS
RIGHT HERE IN AMERICA!
IN MY PHONE!
AND NEEDS TO BE CRUSHED THIS
VERY SECOND!
DAMN YOU, CANDY!
♪♪
I'M SO GOOD AT THIS!
YOU KNOW WHAT, APPLE'S JUST A
COMPANY.
THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO GET BY.
I'M SURE THEY'D FIX A LOT OF
THESE WORKING CONDITIONS IF THEY
COULD ONLY AFFORD IT.
>> THIS FALL, FROM OCTOBER
THROUGH DECEMBER, APPLE MADE
MORE MONEY IN ONE QUARTER THAN
ANY COMPANY HAS EVER MADE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE EARTH.
>> Larry: OKAY.
SO THEY CAN AFFORD IT.
BUT I CAN'T AFFORD TO GIVE UP
CANDY CRUSH!
ALRIGHT?
TO HELP US SORT THIS
ETHICAL-TECHNOLOGICAL DILEMMA,
WE TURN TO "THE NIGHTLY SHOW"
CONTRIBUTOR MIKE YARD.
MIKE, THANKS FOR BEING ON THE
SHOW.
>> THANKS, LAWRENCE.
>> Larry: SO HOW CAN I STILL
ENJOY CANDY CRUSH AND BE
RESPONSIBLE?
>> YOU CAN'T.
YOU GOTTA DO WHAT I DID AND GO
FULL AMISH.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: COMPLETELY IGNORE
ALL MODERN DAY TECHNOLOGY?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
ANY PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY CORRUPTS
YOU.
COMPUTERS HAVE CIRCUIT BOARDS
MADE WITH MINERALS.
MOST OF THOSE MINERALS COME FROM
SLAVE LABOR IN THE CONGO.
SO NO TECHNOLOGY.
AND THAT'S HOW WE AMISH DO, BABY
>> Larry: THAT SEEMS PRETTY
EXTREME.
LIKE NO ONE'S GOING TO DO THAT.
>> THEN ENJOY THE BLOOD ON YOUR
HANDS, MY BROTHER
>> Larry: MIKE, WE'VE NEVER
FACED ANYTHING LIKE THIS
BEFORE -- I'M SURE ONCE WE PUT
OUR HEADS TOGETHER, WE'LL FIND A
SOLUTION THAT DOESN'T INVOLVE
CHANGING YOUR ENTIRE LIFESTYLE
AND RELIGION.
>> ALL THIS TECHNOLOGY IS JUST
MODERN-DAY COTTON.
>> Larry: WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
THE SAME WAY WE'RE IGNORING
HOW THIS STUFF GETS MADE IS THE
SAME WAY A NORTHERNER IN THE
1850s WAS FEELING ABOUT A
COMFORTABLE PAIR OF COTTON
DRAWERS!
THEY'D BE, LIKE, "THIS BE A
SPLENDID PANTALOON, 'TWAS
THRIFTY!
I GIVE NOT A FIG HOW 'TWAS MADE!
BUT IF YOU'RE A SLAVE IN THE
SOUTH, YOU'RE LIKE, (BLEEP)
COTTON!
LET THOSE MOTHER (BLEEP) WEAR
BURLAP BOXERS!
>> Larry: I THINK I UNDERSTAND
YOUR POINT.
IF THAT'S TRUE ABOUT TECHNOLOGY,
IT MUST BE TRUE ABOUT A LOT OF
OTHER STUFF WE HAVE.
>> GO HARD OR GO HOME.
THAT'S WHY I'M AMISH.
ISH.
>> Larry: ISH?
IF I WERE TRULY AMISH, THESE
CAMERAS WOULD BE STEALING MY
SOUL RIGHT NOW.
>> Larry: OH, OKAY.
>> PLUS, I DON'T BUY INTO THAT
NO-SEX-BEFORE-MARRIAGE (BLEEP).
YOU EVER HAD SEX WITH AN AMISH
GIRL?
I MEAN --
>> Larry: OKAY, THAT'S ENOUGH,
MIKE.
SO HOW ARE YOU GOING TO EARN A
LIVING IF YOU'RE AMISH?
>> COMEDY.
>> Larry: YOU'RE STILL DOING
COMEDY?
>> HELL, YEAH!
(BLEEP) PLOWING FIELDS -- I'VE
REINVENTED MYSELF AS JACOB
STOLTZFUSS, LANCASTER COUNTY'S
PREMIER AMISH STANDUP COMIC!
LAWRENCE, THE AMISH ACTUALLY PAY
THEIR ACTS GOOD MONEY!
>> Larry: WHAT KIND OF
MATERIAL DO YOU DO?
>> PENNSYLVANIA DUTCH PUT UP A
BARN LIKE THIS!
MMM, I'M PUTTING UP A BARN...
OHIO DUTCH PUT UP A BARN LIKE
THIS!
GET UP THERE!
>> Larry: OH, I THINK WE GET
IT --
>> WHAT'S THE DEAL WITH THE
AIRPLANE FOOD?
NO, LITERALLY, WHAT'S THE DEAL
WITH IT -- I'VE NEVER BEEN ON AN
AIRPLANE!
>> Larry: LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
KILLING IT OUT WILL!
>> I'M HEADLINING AT THE MIRTH
SILO IN TWO WEEKS.
GET YOUR TICKETS NOW!
>> Larry: MIKE YARD,
EVERYBODY!
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.